こんにちわ
はじめしゃちょーです。
わたくし以前の動画で
あるゴルフクラブを
へし折ってしまいました．．．
ぼくが折ってしまったゴルフクラブなんですけれども
ぼくゴルフをやったことがなくて
ゴルフがどんなものなのかってことを全く知らなくて
まぁ、ちょっと使用用途とかも分からずに
ぼくの間違った使い方であのゴルフクラブを折ってしまいました
いろんなご迷惑をおかけしてしまったので
実はあの後すぐ
広田ゴルフさんと連絡を取り
直接広田ゴルフさんを訪問させていただき
ぼくと事務所の方で謝罪させていただきました
で、今回なぜこのようなことになったのかと言いますと
まず、そもそもぼくにゴルフの知識がなかった
間違いなくそこだと思っております
その結果、ゴルフしている方なら誰しも大切にするゴルフクラブってものをへし折ってしまったんですけれども
広田ゴルフさんと話し合った結果
改めて
しなるゴルフ、ロジャーキングを提供して頂きました！！
本当に有難うございます！
そして申し訳ないです…
広田ゴルフさん、良い方たちで、知識がないから仕方ない
とは言いつつも、やはりすごい迷惑をかけてしまったので
今回！
広田ゴルフさんに直々に是非、この私はじめしゃちょーに
このロジャーキングの正しい使い方を皆さんに広めて欲しいというわけで
広田ゴルフさんに謝罪した後
実は！
ゴルフのレッスンを受けまくっておりました
どうぞ！
ピュッピュッピュッピュ　♪
あの僕、ゴルフクラブまともに持ったこともないし
全くやったこともないので、ゼロからのスタートだったんですけれども
ボヨヨーン　♪
へ★た★く★そ
みっちり練習させていただきました
初めてなので全くやり方がわかんないです
0だからね、本当に。
0から今から、レッスンを
ガラガラガラガラガラガラ
どこまで上達出来るか、見せてやろうと思います
いまそれ本当に当てようとしてたん？
当てようとしとるよ、まじで
プロを待ちましょう
うん、それがいいと思います
難しいっすね
はい！　よろしくお願いします
自分の中で左手で
拳がたぶん２つとか見えるくらい
すーっと下へおろしましょう
じゃな！